If you remember in our last slide, one of the choices was whether you were using
physical or virtual distribution channels.
Let's take a look at virtual channels, which are not only the web but also might include
iPhone apps or the Cloud as well.
The first choice might be dedicated e-commerce.
That is you might have a website that belongs to you and that is one choice.
Another choice is that you might have an app that runs on a mobile device,
and mobile devices like Android or Apple and others and Microsoft require you to use
their platform app store and so that might be a choice.
Another choice is to use two-step distribution that is there might be other distributors
who have major web presences like Amazon, Wal-Mart, other local and regional stores.
And you might actually sell your virtual products through theirs or physical products.
You might use an aggregator. An aggregator is somebody who takes a vertical market approach.
Insurance, shoes, etc. Some examples are, for insurance, Lending Tree or Zappos.
Another might be social commerce.
Social commerce sites for distribution might include Facebook, Twitter, etc.
Zynga, which is a video game company, uses predominantly Facebook as its platform.
And then finally flash sales.
Examples include Groupon and Living Social.
Now, the first instinct of almost any startup founder is when you understand all the choices for
distribution channels is to say yes.
And the question is, yes to what? You can't afford to pick multiple channels on day one.
Most successful startups pick one of these and then may eventually expand into others.
So the question for you is what's going to be your first distribution channel
on the web, Cloud, or for mobile devices?